I think the most important thing for a
guy in regards to formal wear is just
making sure that it fits and looking
comfortable in what you wearing my
collections start from a very classic
point of view almost feel like there are
two sides to each collection there's the
more classic hand tailored side but then
within my collections are more
conceptual versions of how I perceive
classic clothing dress code from the Met
Ball this year is white tie and Tails my
reaction when I heard was I think it's
gonna be refreshing to see how the guys
make the effort I've been doing formal
pieces in my collections from the
beginning so I have pieces from my
archives that are gonna be used for the
evening I'm wearing my interpretation
white I can say house it's gonna be
definitely different than what other
people are gonna be wearing
this is very similar to what I'm wearing
more of a hybrid between the morning
coat and tail coat and I love wearing
shorts so my creative license is I'm
gonna be wearing shorts this is another
kilt that will be worn at the Met Ball I
designed and developed this har gow
fabric for this one collection and
dipped in red white and blue grosgrain
which is also something signature to my
collections this tail coat was an
interpretation of a more classic tail
coat the tails are somewhat longer than
the Shetland wool that was developed for
this specific collection which was I
call it the circus collection
the Met Ball is a true experience it is
at such a high level and you know
everyone there but you don't really know
them hi and the biggest proponent of
guys just being comfortable with with
whatever they want to do I love seeing
people just being through individuals
and being confident in that